RESPONSE.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
>> YOU ARE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: NEWS YOU CAN
BELIEVE:  RETIRED PROFESSOR
OF RUSSIAN STUDIES AT NYU
AND PRINCETON AND AUTHOR OF
THE FANTASTIC BOOK "WAR WITH
RUSSIA" FROM PUTIN AND
UKRAINE TO TRUMP AND RUSSIA
GATE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WITH THE STEELE
DOSSIER AND I DON'T WANT TO
RE-LITIGATE THE YEAR WE
SPENT.
NOW SOLICITING INFORMATION
FROM GOVERNMENT IS
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
THE STEELE DOSSIER THE BASIS
OF THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION,
WAS THAT INFORMATION IN
WHOLE OR PART FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT?
>> WELL, BY THE WAY, THE
FIRST TIME WE METHOD ON YOUR
PROGRAM WAS TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO WHEN THE STEELE
DOSSIER WAS PUBLISHED.
I THINK IT WAS JANUARY 2,
'17.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT THEN.
I SAID TO YOU THEN THIS IS
CLEARLY SOMETHING CONCOCTED
PROBABLY BY INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AROUND THE WORLD.
AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S TURNED
OUT TO BE.
STEELE'S PREMISE, WHICH GOT
HIM ATTENTION, WAS THAT HE
GOT ALL THIS FROM SOURCES
HIGH IN THE KREMLIN.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
KREMLIN SOURCES.
BUT THE STORY DIDN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE BECAUSE THE
DOSSIER SAID PUTIN WANTED TO
ELECT TRUMP SO WHY THEN WE
ASK OURSELVES WOULD PUTIN'S
OWN AGENTS GIVE STEELE DIRT
ON TRUMP TO DESTROY HIS
CANDIDACY?
THE WHOLE STEELE DOCUMENT
MADE VERY LITTLE SENSE.
BY THE WAY, WE NOW KNOW THAT
STEELE WAS MORE OF A COME
POSER THAN A WRITER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CONTRIBUTED
TO IT, INCLUDING THE WIFE OF
A VERY HIGH RANKING AMERICAN
FBI AGENT, LOUISE ZORE.
SHE SAID SHE RESEARCHED FOR
STEELE SO I ASSUME THAT'S
WHAT IT MEANS.
TRUCK TRUCK PRETTY STUNNING.
HAVE YOU BEEN IN AND AROUND
THIS WORLD FOR MANY DECADES.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS?
THIS APPEARS TO BE IN PART
AN INTELLIGENCE OPERATION
AIMED AT A SITTING U.S.
PRESIDENT.
IS THERE PRECEDENT FOR THIS
HISTORICALLY.
>> HAVE YOU ASKED ME TO GO
SOME PLACE WE CAN'T GO AT
LENGTH.
COMING DOWN HERE, I ASKED
MYSELF, HAVE WE EVER HAD A
PRESIDENTIAL SCANDAL LIKE
THIS IN AMERICA?
NO.
I CAN'T THINK OF ONE.
THEN, BECAUSE I STUDY SOVIET
UNION AS A PROFESSION, I ASK
MYSELF DID THE RUSSIAN
SECRET POLICE THE KGB RUN
OWN OPERATIONS AGAINST
SOVIET LEADERS TO PURSUE
POLICIES THEY DIDN'T LIKE IN
THE ANSWER IS YES,
PARTICULARLY DETANT RELATED
POLICIES.
NOW I CONNECT DOTS AND FEEL
FREE TO TELL ME I SHOULDN'T
CONNECT THESE DOTS, THAT
IT'S A CRAZY RUSSIANIST
THINKING.
ALL OF THIS RUSSIAN STUFF
SEEMS TO HAVE ORIGINATED,
THAT'S WHAT STEELE TELLS US
WITH INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES,
AMERICAN AND FOREIGN.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHY
AND WE NEED TO KNOW THIS.
THEY SET OUT TO DESTROY
TRUMP AS A CANDIDATE IN 2016
AND THEN AS A PRESIDENT.
AFTER ALL, OTHER AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS HAD PURSUED
COOPERATION WITH RUSSIA.
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT TRUMP THAT
DETERMINED THEM TO DESTROY
HIM?
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE
QUESTION.
I HAVE THEORIES BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY ARE RIGHT.